hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my hunger games mockingjay review
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
see it but if you haven't I'm gonna do
my non-spoilery part first and then I'll
get into spoilers to talk about specific
moments I don't have quite the history
with The Hunger Games books as I do with
Song of Ice and Fire and Game of Thrones
on TV I only read the first one the
first Hunger Games book so when I saw
Catching Fire and now this one I didn't
know what was gonna happen going into it
I just feel like your focus is drawn to
different things when you already know
what the story is versus not knowing
even if you're not a book reader though
you could feel this giant shift in the
tone of the film within the first 15
minutes like it's completely not a big
event film anymore it's something
totally different
the first two films were all about The
Hunger Games themselves like these big
epic events now that the line has been
drawn in the sand between these two big
powers inside Panem it's much more about
the power of propaganda and the way it's
used
I mean propaganda was a big part of the
first two movies like whenever they made
the tributes go on caesar's show it was
just that during those moments it was
very clear it was all meant to be
and the characters are just
trying to survive it the difference in
Mockingjay I think is that the
propaganda have become the games I mean
they taken the place that the games
serve in the story it's still about this
big call to action and the masses and
the idea of perceived truth versus
actual truth
it's just now we get to hear more than
just the one side story some of the most
fun parts in the film come from them
telling the rebel side of the story
their side of the propaganda I mean the
circumstances are still super depressing
I mean that's part of the Hunger Games
thing it's post-apocalyptic very much of
a downer environment but all the
aspirational aspects of the propaganda
are gone Katniss just as always still
the reluctant non-traditional hero I
love Jennifer Lawrence as a hero Katniss
is a very different pill to swallow than
say someone from an Avengers film I
think that's why a lot of people like
The Hunger Games so much just because
it's so different from a traditional
action film they're still able to get a
lot of good laughs in it's even funnier
when you listen to what the actor said
about the pranks they played on each
other while they were filming Liam
Hemsworth said that any time he had a
kissing scene with Jennifer Lawrence
just to be funny she'd always eat a ton
of garlic or something really gross
right before they did it and Elizabeth
Banks as Effie always brings a lot of
humor into the story of all the
films I enjoy her the most in this film
versus Hunger Games and Catching Fire
she's always been the clown but now
she's like the sad clown which for some
reason is funnier to me I was never a
giant fan of Woody Harrelson's Haymitch
in real life he does share a lot of
payment jizz qualities like he is a
crazy recovering drug addict but I
always felt like he was miscast in this
role he has this strange acting style
that feels like it just does not fit in
a really serious genre film like this
and Mockingjay is way more serious than
the first two films he does a lot better
when he gets to be ridiculous like
Zombieland completely ridiculous film he
is totally appropriate for that Julianne
Moore and Philip Seymour Hoffman totally
amazing together not surprised at all
they're both amazing character actors so
you just instantly forget that it's them
it's always fun to watch actors
disappear into their characters the
producers the film actually made this
big point to state that they didn't use
CG to complete Philip Seymour Hoffman
scenes he died before he finished his
last couple of scenes and they either
had the choice of doing CG on another
actors face or just giving his dialogue
to someone else and they just chose the
second route it's not something you
notice but they made a really big deal
about it before the movie came out and
just to address some of the criticism of
them breaking the movie into two parts I
think the funniest comment I saw on
Twitter was Duncan Jones the director
that's doing Warcraft right now he said
something like the only reason to break
the third movie in a trilogy into two
parts is because you want to buy a
big-ass yacht I do agree with the
sentiment I mean if you think about it
the first 200 games films were based on
the first two books if they could do
both those books in one film they could
do the third book in one film if you
really hate that Hollywood is doing this
with franchise movies now you have to
blame Harry Potter and Warner Brothers
they're the first big franchise to do
that two-part finale but to break the
last film in their franchise into two
films so they would have one more year
of a guaranteed profit Warner Brothers
did it again with the third Hobbit movie
The Hobbit was actually originally gonna
be directed by Guillermo del Toro and be
just one film then Warner Brothers
turned it into two films brought Peter
Jackson back added a whole bunch of
stuff that was not in the books cut to a
little bit later they had a third film
that's pretty much all made up stuff
that's not in the book it's just now
studios can turn what would normally be
a five hundred million dollar profit
over a couple years into a two to three
billion-dollar profit over the span of
like the next 10 years the trend isn't
going away anytime soon Disney's doing
it with the Marvel films now Avengers 3
totally gonna be broken into two films
let's all be honest with ourselves for a
second I mean no matter how many movies
they break these into we're still gonna
pay to go see them
I'm definitely part of the problem
myself and that I financially support
this stuff if no one paid to see them
they wouldn't do this
Mockingjay is still a totally fun ride
and if you haven't read the books
there's some great big set pieces
that'll freak you out in a really
awesome way the ending totally awesome
WTF moment if you have read the books
you will still cry her eyes out the
whole time
if you haven't seen it yet it's still
totally worth the money to pay to see it
in a theater it's still a great film but
here's my big question for you guys you
know what was your favorite moment and -
do you care that movies are being broken
into two parts like this so now it's
time to get into spoilers I'm gonna do
my top five moments so just careful if
you haven't seen it here we go general
spoiler warning number five presidents
no facts like I said I had not read
Catching Fire Mockingjay so I actually
learned quite a bit about presidents
know whenever Finnick went on the air
whenever they were jamming airwaves with
spam they were spamming as a way to
attack the Capitals defenses which is
also a pretty cool trick so remember how
I said propaganda was the core of the
film this time around the propaganda are
the games now and there are only two
participants in the ring the Capitol and
the rebels
Finnick explained that he survived in
the capital by trading secrets so it was
fun to listen to him spill his guts
about how President Snow rose to power
like the fact that he uses white roses
to cover the smell of blood in his mouth
from wounds that will never heal
I don't think that humanizes presidents
know in any way he's still just as
terrible as ever
number four Katniss in the studio this
is actually a bit of a funny moment the
first time they tried to make some fake
propaganda it was like the first time
the movie let itself have some fun the
whole beginning is just so depressing
and serious all the Hunger Games movies
in general kind of begin this way just
with an absence of action even sound
it's one of the defining characteristics
of the franchise in that they all just
begin on these downer moments so
watching candidates try to act totally
funny totally hilarious and it brought
Haymitch back into the story even though
he felt a little out of place in
district 13 number three Jennifer
Lawrence sings the hanging tree song I
don't think I've ever heard her sing in
any of her movies but I thought it was
beautifully melancholy
like your happy and sad at the same time
the song was very appropriate to the
story of the movie it kind of
highlighted what was going on in the
movie itself but just in general it was
a great performance
very well-timed very awesome moment
number two if he trinket in district 13
Elizabeth Banks so much more fun this
time around sad clown Effie Trinket has
all this wit in style and no one in
district 13 gives a I was never a
huge fan of her character during the
first two films she just felt like a
little too fancy for me but she's like
the pressure release valve in this one
so she's a welcome break from all this
seriousness Effie for the win and my
number one moment
Peeta Mellark is completely nanners like
I said I went into this not knowing what
the story was so I actually kind of
thought they were gonna do something
different with his character I thought
that President Snow is gonna turn him
into one of those genetically altered
dogs like in Catching Fire like they
were going to have horrific Lee
genetically altered Peeta
I felt some of the editing was a little
misleading but the actual reveal that
Peeta was cranked up on tracker jacker
venom was still a totally great way to
end the movie just in general totally
fun wasn't quite the roller coaster ride
that the other two films were but I
think that was kind of the point The
Hunger Games in general is a nice
antidote to very traditional big action
set piece movies so if you're looking
for something different in like a big
blockbuster film then this is perfect so
there's a lot of stuff happening in the
next couple of days here's a quick
update on what my video schedule is
gonna be so I'm gonna try and get out my
Korra Q&A next and then I'll try and
post Constantine before Walking Dead on
Sunday night in case I'm not able to get
it out fast enough I'll just post
Constantine on Monday though I did see
big hero 6 and interstellar I just
didn't have time to make videos for them
which kind of sucks
since TV is going on break though in the
next couple of weeks I will have more
time in December for Hobbit whatnot and
a bunch of Star Wars Episode 7 stuff be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
please leave all your movie video
requests in the comments when there's
not as much TV on it's a lot easier for
me to do movie videos so I should be
able to do some more in December in case
you guys haven't seen me explain it in
my other videos youtube gave you this
special beta feature to play with if
you're watching this on your mobile
phone or on a tablet there are new links
up here at the top of the frame you can
click on it's the same as the links that
I add over here but right now click here
to catch up on Legend of Korra Kunik
coming in a little bit and click here to
learn all
the new Game of Thrones video game from
telltale games can be totally amazing
thank you so much for watching so I'll
see you guys all tonight hi vibes
you